[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
ce rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on
discute des sujets qui font l'actualité
depuis le début du mois de janvier le
pass culture est devenue aussi scolaire
une part collectif permettra un
professeur de financer des activités
pour sa classe l'académie de versailles
est entré dans le processus en septembre
dernier en lançant une phase de test
alors pourquoi le développer dans les
établissements scolaires on en parle
avec nos invités charline avenel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles béatrice piron
bonsoir bonsoir et demandé à la ville
bonne année à vous aussi vous êtes
député de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines et membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
geneviève domine web bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes professeur référent culture au
lycée jean monnet à la
queue-lez-yvelines et chloé hyvernat
bonsoir bonsoir vous est ambassadrice
lycéenne dans le même établissement le
lycée jean monnet à la
queue-lez-yvelines alors en février 2019
le ministère de la culture déploie le
pass culture plusieurs et a poursuivi
son déploiement depuis trois ans à qui
s'adresse ce passe depuis sa création
quelques précisions
[Musique]
est
ce parce devient donc scolaire en ce
début de mois de janvier béatrice piron
pourquoi justement le rendre accessible
aux établissements
les premières expérimentations quand
lieu depuis 2010 9 ans ont démontré que
certains jeunes nous mêmes mais j'aurais
été déjà notre utilisez pas la totalité
du pass culturel qui leur a été donné
donc on a imaginé et proposait donc de
les initier progressivement bien plus
tôt donc qu'on avait commencé simplement
avec vous forme on va dire d'un cadeau à
18 ans et il a été décidé de leur donner
l'ouvrir le passe bien plus tôt à partir
de 15 ans et un accompagnement donc avec
l'éducation nationale pour pouvoir avec
les enseignants donc leur montrer lors
leur faire des projets collectifs et
leur donner accès donc au niveau de leur
classe aa des spectacles pour leur
donner le goût du spectacle du vivant du
concert avant d'avoir 18 ans
charline avenel votre académie rentrer
dans le processus dès le mois de
septembre 2021 qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous en tant que rectrice de se
passe justement
j'attends beaucoup d'abord ce sont des
moyens qui sont vraiment multiplier
multiplié par trois pour ce qu'on
appelle l'éducation artistique et
culturelle donc c'est tout à fait
considérable
la députée vient d'expliquer le rôle que
peut avoir l'éducation nationale dans le
round accompagnement vers le choix
culturels vers la dépense est aussi ça
se fait parce que on a déjà un travail
très important qui est fait par les
professeurs dans laquelle humide à ça il
y en a eu huit cents enseignants
référents qui vont accompagner ses
élèves à être des acteurs de
consommation culturelle quand leurs
parties collectives et pour leur partie
individuelle et puisqu'on a expérimenté
dans les six collèges lycées qui ont
participé à cette expérimentation 6000
élèves concernés et bien c'est cette
idée formidable de faire émerger des
ambassadeurs culture dont chloé ici est
la représentante
vous le voyez se développer actuellement
commandant l'académie se sont quand même
24 bassin d'éducation répartis dans les
quatre départements l'académie de
versailles c'est le val d'oise les
hauts-de-seine l'essonne et les yvelines
alors ce que j'ai pu observer depuis le
début de cette expérimentation d'abord
c'est l'effet de volume le fait qu on
décuple complètement l'action au sein
d'un établissement et celui de même
madame de la queue-lez-yvelines le lycée
jean monnet qui est ici elle
représentait eh bien on voit qu'il y
avait un noyau de processeurs
aujourd'hui avec le pass culture je
pense qu'on a multiplié par par simple
nombre de professeurs qui sont impliqués
sur ses actions culturelles donc moi je
vois déjà un effet volume de ce qui va
se passer ensuite ce que je vois et ce
que j'attends c'est un effet qualitatif
les autres oeuvres culturelles sont en
train de changer l'europe de l'améliorer
de l'augmenter par exemple on veut un
théâtre et on va faire tout un travail
sur les costumes sur les décors donc les
l'offre culturelle va s'ajuster pour
toucher un très grand nombre de jeunes
d'enseignants et améliorer cette offre
culturelle
béatrice piron c'est ça la culture a
toute sa place au sein de l'enseignement
c'est pas deux mondes deux mondes est
séparé non bien sûr que non non non donc
depuis toujours l'enseignement et
éducation nationale a participé à la
découverte du théâtre que ce soit des
classiques et parfois des pièces
modernes alors c'est vrai que il ya une
étude qui est toujours fait par le livre
mais c'est très bien c'est très
intéressant que les élèves puissent
aussi voir du théâtre en tant que
spectacle vivant et puis après il ya la
musique il ya le concert il y a
également tout ce qui est lecture a donc
aujourd'hui les constats faits dans les
consommations des jeunes donc on dépasse
depuis une année au mois puisque ça
avait été généralisé assez largement
l'année dernière
80 % des dépenses se font par le livre
c'est parce que c'est effectivement le
point d'accès à la culture le plus
proche géographiquement c'est les
librairies où il ya le plus un vent de
pointe de librairies en france alors
maintenant il va falloir apprendre aux
jeunes à aller un petit peu plus loin à
aller jusqu au cinéma qu'au théâtre
jusqu'à la salle de concert et ça ça
peut être faire un accompagnement avec
le lycée effectivement alors on l'a dit
ça a été mentionné 800 professeurs son
référent culture il y en a une avec nous
geneviève dominera vous êtes l'un de ses
800 professeurs vous êtes professeur
documentaliste au lycée jean monnet à la
queue-lez-yvelines qu'est ce que ça
apporte dans l'enseignement comment on
intègre cette culture plus tôt on va
dire extérieur même si le mot n'est pas
nécessairement le long dans un projet
pédagogique
alors tout simplement effectivement donc
cette culture allait vraiment ou au
coeur de tous nos projets c'est donc ça
s'appuie sur une pédagogie de projet
toujours avec un partenariat
j'insisterai moment beaucoup sur cette
idée de partenariat parce que tous ces
projets ne n'aurait pas de sens et ne
pouvait pas se faire sans les nos
partenaires donc de longue date que nous
avons surtout c'est très important dans
notre établissement qui est située en
zone rurale donc éloigné effectivement
des grands centres culturels des grands
théâtres même si l'humour nous allons
parfois effectivement sur versailles sur
le théâtre sur la scène nationale de 50
ans guide voir aussi bien entendu sur
paris mais nous essayons vraiment de
privilégier nos acteurs de terrain et
c'est avec eux que nous montons des
projets culturels toujours en s'appuyant
en essayant de s'appuyer dans sur les
trois piliers de le ac c'est à dire dans
la pratique la pratique artistique
on a parlé tout à l'heure vous avez
parlé de théâtre mais ça peut être aussi
eu ça peut être aussi sur la
photographie ça peut être sur le cinéma
ça peut être sur les arts de la rue et
c'est sur la photographie sur le cirque
sur les connaissances parce que cette
culture s'appuie effectivement sur des
connaissances et aussi sur la rencontre
à la fois avec des artistes mais aussi
avec des biens culturels et voilà
comment cette culture vient directement
dans l'établissement et ça fait partie
un petit peu de notre façon maintenant
de procéder je pense que ce sont des les
acquis pour notre établissement n'est et
comment ça s'appelle nos partenaires
viennent dans nos établissements je
pense qu'il se sent très bien chez nous
et nous nous sentons aussi très bien
chez eux effectivement je pense que
c'est la force de ces échanges qui ont
été de longue date qui sont mis en place
dans l'établissement accompagné aussi
par des parmi mes collègues qui sont
effectivement toujours partant y en a de
plus en plus et une grâce à ce pass
culture nos collègues qui peut être
édité aussi à se lancer sur des projets
vont peut-être amorcé aussi que des
projets peut-être par exemple par une
sortie culturelle et cela va leur donner
envie aussi certainement aussi de
s'engager après dans des projets plus
ambitieux voilà et je pense que ça
faisait ça fait partie vraiment de là
cette culture fait partie de la culture
générale de notre établissement cette
culture elle est destinée aux élèves les
élèves sont aussi sollicités clos
hivernale vous étudiez aussi à vous
étudiez pas aussi vous êtes et d'élèves
au lycée jean monnet en décembre 2021 il
y avait trois ambassadrices dans votre
établissement vous en est une qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé vous à vous engager
pour être honnête au début je ne savais
pas vraiment dans quoi je m'embarquais
mais madame 2000 on m'a tout de suite
parlé du fait que
c'était que vous rendre la culture plus
accessible en fait tous les élèves de
notre établissement et nos maux de but
c'est surtout de gérer la communication
entre mano était les établissements avec
lesquels on fait des collaborations et
les élèves et leur proposer des
partenariats et des possibilités donc
c'est surtout faire découvrir des choses
aux autres qui motive
souvent on a alors moi le lycée remonte
à une quinzaine d'années maintenant
on part c'est par le livre c'est ce
qu'on disait on avait les cours de
littérature de savoir que vous pouvez
aller à la rencontre de voir des pièces
que vous avez étudié est ce que ça vous
a motivé aussi de vous de vous
renseigner là dessus pour vous
rapprocher à prés de vaux vos collègues
au sein de votre établissement
je pense que c'est clairement une
meilleure façon d'apprendre et
on essaie de voir avec beaucoup de
professeurs pour mettre en place des
projets comme ça pour motiver tout le
monde parce que se cantonner à juste
lire une pièce c'est quand même moins
sympa à quai les lavoirs et
la pédagogie est en train d'évoluer dans
un sens vraiment positif je pense
charlie d'avesnelles on a l'exemple d'un
professeur d'un élève qui s'engagent
dans ce pass culture c'était important
aussi que tous les acteurs soient
concernés sensibiliser avant même de le
mettre en place se passe
oui absolument
donc nous on a engagé au niveau
l'académie programme de formation
d'accompagnement des enseignants parce
que même s'ils sont déjà très impliqués
leur rhône va un peu se déplacer dans
les semaines et mois à venir dans
l'accompagnement des jeunes vers cet
acte nouveau de consommation culturelle
de choix éclairé donc on a eu des
sessions de formation l'accompagnement
des enseignants et puis vraiment moi je
me réjouis que nous ayons inventé
ce nouveau rôle d'ambassadeur des jeunes
je m'en réjouis parce que on avait eu à
peine l'idée que les jeunes eux mêmes
s'en sont emparés et donc ont écrit leur
propre fiche de poste qui m'ont
présentée et je vois comment sa vie
parce que je suis allé dans ce dc j'ai
vu chloé dix ans avec ses camarades en
fait nous ce qu'on a envie de faire
notre part individuelle et bien c'est
peut-être de se concerter et d'aller un
concert ensemble de proposer même
quelque chose de collectif pour
l'utilisation de notre part individuelle
donc voilà je veux et les jeunes sont en
train de s'en emparer et je suis
persuadé qu'avec ce réseau très puissant
des enseignants très motivés très
qualifiés et avec l'énergie des jeunes
ambassadeurs je suis persuadé que le
bass culture à présent à partir de 15
ans va être un véritable succès
geneviève domine oit
donc il ya déjà des événements qui ont
lieu dans votre établissement est ce que
les professeurs viennent spontanément
vers vous pour s'informer de ce qui est
possible à ils viennent peut-être même
avec leurs propres idées est ce que
c'est ça tu adaptes à toutes les
matières
oui lorsque effectivement déjà nous
avons nous avions une habitude de monter
des projets des projets
interdisciplinaires dans lesquels on
peut associer temps par exemple et des
enseignants de lettres mais aussi de
deux langues de sciences économiques et
sociales de mathématiques d'éducation
physique et sportive
donc là déjà l'habitude de travailler
ensemble existe déjà ensuite il a fallu
effectivement m présenté ce pass culture
organisé des réunions organisées des
réunions surtout avec l'aide aussi de
les cvl ensuite de nos ambassadeurs
culture s'appuyer aussi à la fois pas
sur notre équipe de direction sur la vie
scolaire donc effectivement il faut ça
commence à prendre forme il faut
effectivement années 60 c'est aussi
notre rôle de professeur référent
culture c'est de présenter les offres et
aussi bien sûr d'accompagner et de dire
à nos collègues oui nous sommes là pour
vous aider vous proposez vous aider à
monter des projets et je pense que ça va
faire son chemin progressivement voilà
je suis confiante en tout cas c'est
certain
clo hivernale justement à votre âge
comme un autre comment est ce qu'on
découvre peut-être d'autres sites des
lieux des cultures qu'on ne connaît pas
on va j'imagine discuter avec les
camarades mais vous échangez que vos
professeurs aussi
ah oui beaucoup et j'ai beaucoup de
professeurs qui sont très intéressés pas
forcément ceux littérature ou de choses
comme ça mais j'ai déjà vu des
professeurs qui m'ont conseillé des
pièces ou des films qui étaient vraiment
bien et on a pu en discuter donc ouais
vraiment le les échanges se fait
principalement par la voir on peut aussi
faire des recherches par internet de nos
jours en fait c'est assez facile d'être
curieux
et bien tu respires on vient d'entendre
le mot curiosité c'est aussi l'idée de
ce pass culture d'ouvrir un monde qu'on
n'imaginait pas être pouvoir être le
sien oui tout à fait ce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup précisé que ça fonctionnait
aussi à travers une application donc et
donc les jeunes sont aujourd'hui très à
l'aise donc sur le numérique et ont la
possibilité de télécharger cette
application aujourd'hui et déjà 830
mille jeunes qui se sont inscrits qui
ont donc consommé sur cette application
est donc à partir du mois de janvier va
être ouvert donc en fonction de trois
dates les 17 ans premier don peut 10
janvier les secours ont 16 ans à partir
du 20 janvier et ceux qui ont 15 ans à
partir du 31 janvier donc sur
l'application il songer aux plats ou
gaziers et il peut voir en fin de compte
tout des événements toutes les offres
culturelles qui existent sur le
territoire autour de chez eux et donc
ils peuvent très bien étendre le
territoire un petit peu plus loin et à
les découvrir pour vous 10e et damas
vers sac ou voire même peut-être jusqu'à
paris un spectacle qui pourrait et qui
pourraient les intéresser et charline
avenel on le disait tout à l'heure le
pass culture a débuté dans l'académie
par une expérimentation il y avait six
établissements similaires comment
justement à fonctionner cette
expérimentation vous étiez longtemps
dans une phase de test où ça a pris tout
de suite et vous avez pu le dispatcher
facilement dans les autres
établissements
on va dire que cette phase
d'expérimentation a permis d'essuyer les
plâtres quand on débute un processus
il ya besoin de mettre en place des
choses obtenir les codes donc ça nous a
permis aux loups rodés mais tout de
suite on a eu beaucoup d'appétence tout
de suite on a eu des projets qu'ils sont
montés je suis allé en voir dans une
salle
le spectacle juste à côté du lycée très
intéressant de voir très concrètement ce
qui s'est passé pour certains lycées
soit le cas du lycée jean-monnet la
queue-lez-yvelines
s'est orienté vers une offre de
proximité
la salle de spectacle juste à côté à
proposer des offres singulière nouvelle
exprès pour les jeunes du lycée soit ça
donnait l'occasion aux élèves de
diversifier leurs pratiques et les lieux
de leurs pratiques culturelles je crois
que vous êtes allés au théâtre
montansier à versailles
et donc voilà dans cette expérience dans
cette expérimentation on a déjà pu voir
ce que je disais c'est à dire une offre
augmenté de proximité une offre nouvelle
qui déplace les élèves et qui déplace
les pratiques et puis quand on en aux
élèves ce qu'ils ont envie de faire avec
ce pass culture alors on a soit des
jeunes qui me disent que ils ont envie
d'acheter des mangas parce qu'ils aiment
les mangas et puis on a aussi des jeunes
qui disent moi jamais je suis allé à
l'opéra je rêve d'aller à l'opéra voilà
ce qui est ce qu'on a pu constater
mettre en oeuvre alors évidemment dans
ce début janvier on est dans une
situation sanitaire qui ne nous permet
pas de
faire les déplacements culturels qui
était prévu dans le lycée par exemple
vous les avez légèrement suspendus pour
l'instant très vite la programmation
culturelle va se mettre en place dans
chacun des lycées de l'académie oui
justement on vient de mentionner
l'épidémie de kovy 19 on est dans une
période où mikron fait annuler certaines
choses bêtes respirons c'était aussi
l'occasion de profiter de cette jeunesse
qui est entre deux eaux qui c'est une
jeunesse et au moment où on veut sortir
on ne peut plus trop les salles de
théâtre ont des jauges on redonne goût à
la culture
alors on sait bien que le coc vide a eu
un impact très négatif sur les jeunes et
sur le moral des jeunes mais on essaye
au maximum de laisser les choses
devraient donc les jauges sont sur les
gros événements l'instant et il ya quand
même encore là au public et
contrairement à il ya deux ans on peut
aujourd'hui continuer à aller au cinéma
aller au théâtre donc ce n'est pas
totalement arrêtez je pense qu'il faut
tout faire pour maintenir les services
ouverts parce qu'on en a besoin on a
besoin de se changer les idées et on a
besoin de culture ça fait partie des
essentiels de la vie on le sait
maintenant donc on sait aujourd'hui
comment faire pour se protéger protéger
les autres donc on insiste beaucoup sur
la vaccination et on espère que tout le
monde pourra bientôt donc être vaccinés
accéder donc à ces lieux de culture qui
sont essentiels pour nous et c'est
important oui on a on disait aussi il ya
déjà eu des choses donc au lycée jean
monnet geneviève dominant vous avez dans
les actions on a parlé du malade
imaginaire qui a été fait au théâtre
montansier il ya deux classes qui ont pu
y assister il ya une fanfare qui a
déambulé au sein même des locaux de
l'établissement il y a en fait plein
d'idées j'imagine qui vous arrive et se
passe vous permet de les concrétiser
grâce au pass culture votre lycée a
bénéficié de 29 mille euros
supplémentaires pour désert c'est ce
qu'ils sont les actions d'éducation
artistique et culturelle
oui alors on ad on a pu en bénéficier en
partie line et de toute façon je pense
que c'est surtout objectivement il ya du
quantitatif mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment s'inscrire dans le qualitatif
et propose effectivement des actions de
qualité à nos élèves donc des actions de
qualité est aussi très diversifié donc
effectivement une grande fanfare a
déboulé dans l'établissement donc qui
apporte effectivement je pense des
moments de gaieté d'honneur on en a bien
deux lancements dans l'établissement
parce que parfois effectivement une
morosité s'installe à il faut pas en
être conscient voilà des sorties aussi
donc théâtrale donc on a parlé de
comment ça pète de versailles mais aussi
les une sortie donc au théâtre de
l'odéon pour les frères karamazov des
sorties donc à la philharmonie les
sorties aussi pour voir des pièces de
théâtre et aussi donc on va aussi
proposé d'enrichir effectivement ce qui
est important aussi la pratique
artistique voilà si nous avions par
exemple des classes déjà qu'ils étaient
engagés dans des projets de la pratique
je pense là nous avons des classes sur
des projets de pratique artistique soit
de n'importe où de danse de hip hop mais
aussi donc de de musique on va proposer
à d'autres classes de participer donc
d'élargir heureuse cette offre et ça je
pense que la pratique artistique là
aussi c'est important il ya des projets
aussi qui sont hyper intéressant qui
sont proposés donc par une structure
culturelle de proximité à gambe et donc
il eu lieu donc il va travailler dans
mon cas n'est que la scène nationale de
saint quentin l'idée c'est de faire
découvrir la programmation donc du
théâtre à une classe de terminale et de
proposer à ses élèves de choisir
collectivement une sortie une sortie ça
peut être une sortie théâtre à ça peut
être pour voir un spectacle de cirque
etc sur saint-quentin donc que les
élèves vont devoir s'interroger à la
fois sur leurs pratiques culturelles
leurs habitudes et ce n'est pas toujours
facile quand on va par exemple chlorés
pourra le dire choix n'est le nom une
pièce de théâtre c'est pas toujours
facile choisir une pièce de théâtre à
deux c'est encore plus difficile des 30
élèves ça va être quand même un certain
paris donc les élèves vont réfléchir
ensemble ont voté et vont choisir une
pièce pour aller la voir ensemble donc
là ce sont des initiatives qui sont
proposés par nos partenaires qui sont
originales et qui s'inscrivent
parfaitement effectivement dans la
philosophie du pass culture et justement
je voulais voir avec vous chloé hyvernat
sq dans se passe il y à la part
collective c'est de ce dont on parle
depuis début il ya aussi la part
individuelle vous avez le droit à un
certain montant est ce que vous grâce à
cela vous vous permettez des choses que
vous n'auriez pas fait auparavant parce
que vous n'osiez pas peut-être demander
à vos parents vous n'osiez pas il y
accéder vous même
clou et je sais pas si vous m'avez
entendu chloé verna j'ai l'impression
que nous l'avons perdu alors semblerait
que chloé gouvernance on est perdu la
connexion donc vous verrez conclure avec
vous madame piron
clos il nous a dit tout à l'heure à
quartz est qu elle avait très envie de
s'acheter des livres et elle avait très
envie d'aller au théâtre off parce qu'en
effet elle n'a pas forcément l'occasion
d'y aller très souvent et elle nous a
aussi dit qu'elle avait envie de
s'ouvrir de chance de voir d'autres
paysages culturels eh bien je vais
terminer que madame pierrot font
justement longtemps voilà la jeunesse
est présente on a retrouvé chloé
hyvernat mais madame avenel nous à
partager ce que vous disiez avant le
début de l'émission sur votre désir
d'aller au théâtre et d'acheter des
ouvrages madame la députée là on voit
finalement ils ont 13 14 15 ans ils ont
envie ils se mobilisent pour leur
établissement est ce qu'on peut imaginer
plus tard que ce pass s'ouvre sur au 6e
ou 5e voire aux primaires
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de projet
encore pour les jeunes mais pourquoi pas
on essaie aussi de l'étendre plus loin
sur des jeunes adultes ou des étudiants
parce que si on n'a pas toujours le
budget quand on est étudiant on essaie
de faire en sorte que les familles qui
le souhaitent puissent
renchérir pour ajouter du crédit donc
sur l'application c'est à dire qu'un
cadeau de noël pourrait se transformer
en 100 euros de plus sur le pass culture
de l'enfant on essaie de l'élargir aussi
à des publics plus défavorisés peut-être
adultes mais qui n'ont pas l'habitude
d'aller sur les lieux culturels or
justement leur faire découvrir donc il
ya plusieurs pistes évêques qui ment et
les plus jeunes les plus âgés aussi et
et petit à petit il est important d'en
faire la promotion sur tous les lieux de
culture parce que donc notamment mois de
septembre donc je je suis en général
présente dans les forums les
associations parce que toutes les
associations voire même tous les
théâtres aujourd'hui ne sont pas encore
référencé dans l'application et donc il
faut pouvoir permettre à tous les jeunes
de dépenser les 380 euros qui leur sont
donnés donc
sur par exemple un club club théâtre
pour pouvoir faire de la pratique donc
au plus près de chez eux ou aller inter
municipale de certaines villes qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas référencés mais
je vous propose que nous en restions sur
ces mots on va clore ce set une société
jour merci de nous avoir suivis merci à
nous inviter de s'être rendu disponible
la semaine prochaine un nouveau moment
des changes pour discuter des sujets qui
font l'actualité et bien sûr d'ici là
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
il